in light of recent events in attack on
titan season four
may her potato loving innocent soul rest
in peace
i thought a video and dedication to her
would be most fitting this week
and in my research about sasha i found a
piece of information about attack on
titan from a while back actually
from 2017 when season 2 aired that just
makes everything all the more sad in
hindsight
but of course when it rains it uh it
pours
for any anime only watchers who just got
their heart broken this past sunday
i've got some even worse news for you
sasha was
actually always meant to die except
isayama actually planned on killing her
all the way back in season 2 but
couldn't because his editor was crying
his eyes out and begged him not to
yeah let that sink in but it looks like
isayama just couldn't help himself and
just bided his time instead
waiting for an actually even more
emotional time to do it you know at the
end of an arc that has been mainly
filled with success
mass killing of innocent civilians yeah
but success in the broader scope of
things
maybe i don't know if he got like a new
editor or something or the one from
season two just accepted her fate but it
looks like sasha's cruel destiny was
always bound to happen one way or
another
so sasha was originally supposed to die
all the way in chapter 36
which translates to that part of season
2 where she goes back to her hometown
and
saves the child who saw her mother get
eaten by a mindless titan
mind you this was the second episode of
the second season
like that's a really early death that's
before we even knew that reiner and bert
holtz were titan shifters or ymir was a
titan shifter actually
upon reading the storyboard for this
chapter the editor actually admitted to
crying in the bathroom afterwards
because he couldn't handle it
i mean can you blame him don't lie you
did the same thing don't be ashamed if
sasha were alive i think she would have
wanted you to embrace the tears
and this was the first episode or a
chapter i guess where we saw all of the
attention directed towards sasha a side
character and
pretty small side character up until
this point we got to see that she's
actually badass behind you know the
potato eating face that we
love to see anyway and the editor then
persuaded isayama to keep her around
because
it didn't feel like the right time to do
so which i agree with there really isn't
much magnitude to this point in the
story you know
right after the huge final arc of season
one finishing up everything with annie
killing off a character right after that
in the middle of nowhere to a mindless
titan when she doesn't even have her
gear
it just seems kind of unfair it's just a
big nerf to any member of the survey
corps
i guess it would be a testament to her
dedication to defeating the titans
sacrificing her life for the young child
would certainly be a good demonstration
of that
but again i think there really wasn't
enough time to build up who she was as a
character
up until this point granted she hasn't
had a lot of character development
after that either but you know i think
waiting letting fans love her more
and finding a better time to include her
death would feel more natural and more
important to the actual story
because it definitely was integral to
the end of the invasion of marley arc
and what's going forward i talked about
this a lot in my last video
about aaron becoming the villain check
that out if you haven't seen it yet
but sasha's death in season 4 has
actually become the catalyst for the
survey corps
losing their faith in aaron the fact
that he dragged them to marley
into a war that he declared and lost
sasha because of it
is a sacrifice that no one was ready to
handle
i mean armin mikasa that was literally
all of us on sunday afternoon
they loved her as well considering how
many people have been lost over the
course of attack on
titan and how few of the original survey
corps recruits remain
all of whom are actually now in that
blimp i think that each person surviving
after the battle of shigunchina was like
family to each other
you know long ago they all did lose
their families two titans and i think
that honestly her death here is
a pretty poetic callback to the chapter
when sasha was first meant to die
sasha and connie both returned to their
abandoned hometowns at this point
and it just reminds us that there's
nothing left for them there
all they have is each other at this
point and to lose sasha because of
someone who you felt
trusted and believed in this familial
bond is uh
it's terrible and the fact that it's
sasha the most
innocent character basically the one
person who has never really done
anything wrong
just makes it all the more sad and kind
of mean on isayama's part
now to end this video off i wanted to
have a little memorial to sasha so
enjoy i thought that we should have
something like this to send off a
character beloved by everyone
i miss you sasha
[Music]
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses